If you want to see all the references to the
original Halloween films, then stick around
to the end of this video.
Halloween is coming again this year.
I mean, Halloween the holiday comes around
every year, but Halloween the movie has only
come 11 out of the last 40 years.
So that’s a pretty rare occurrence; that’s
only 27.5% of the years.
So uhh, yeah, I’m gonna shut up now and
do the Things You Missed.
So if you pause on the shot of the trick-or-treaters,
and yes I realize I can’t shut up AND tell
you the Things You Missed cause I have to
talk to do this, but you know what I meant.
But if you pause on the trick-or-treaters,
there’s actually a girl wearing an OJ Simpson
jersey.
And for those of you who were not here for
the 90s, OJ was an pro running back who most
people would agree killed his wife and her
friend and got away with it.
There was this huge trial, it was a really
big deal, and OJ was ultimately found not-guilty,
despite a lot of evidence going against him.
You know who else stabbed his victims to death
and got away with it?
That’s right.
Michael Myers did that stuff.
The only difference is that Michael didn’t
write a book about how he would have done
it.
Forty-seven seconds into the new trailer,
there is a scene of a woman wearing a pink
bathrobe with curlers in her hair making a
ham sandwich in her kitchen.
Michael goes in, and comes out with the knife,
presumably after some altercation because
the chair is flipped over in the second shot.
This is a remake of a scene from the original
Halloween II that came out in 1981.
"Harold, you want mayonnaise on your sandwich?
It’s also how Michael gets his knife in
that movie.
"...sometime early this evening.
Authorities have confirmed that all three
of the victims are teenagers.
Two girls and a boy.
Police have..."
As you may know, the new Halloween film for
2018 is the second movie in this timeline,
with Halloween II and everything that comes
after it having never taken place here.
Just the original Halloween and Halloween
2018.
Halloween 2018 is essentially the new Halloween
II, so it’s interesting to see events from
the 1981 Halloween II are still taking place,
almost as if they were destined to happen,
no matter what other events take place to
change the world line.
This next one I’m not counting as one of
the Things You Missed, because there’s really
no significance to it, I just thought it would
be fun to point out, but this Jack-o-Lantern
looks like the logo of The Smiler, a pretty
well known Infinity Coaster at Alton Towers.
As we move up to the house, the shots here
of Michael looking through the window at what
appears to be a woman on the phone, could
be a reference to this scene, also from the
first act of the 1981 Halloween II.
"There was someone screaming next door.
Yeah, Mr. and Mrs. Elrod.
His wife's always picking on him."
There’s also a graveyard scene in the trailer,
where a figure is spotted hiding behind a
tree wearing all white.
While we don’t know for sure that this is
Michael, it would make sense.
The white clothes likely indicate that he
had just escaped from the Sanitarium and headed
straight for his sister’s grave just as
he does in the original Halloween, where he
steals his sister’s tombstone and later
uses it as a prop to display one if his killings.
This time however, Laurie is going to be prepared
for Michael’s onslaught.
She’s stocked up with weapons, one of which
is marked with a lightning bolt and the letters
“KS”.
There is a character named Kara Strode, who
is Laurie’s cousin in the 1995 film, Halloween:
The Curse of Michael Myers.
But I think the KS is more likely pointing
to Karen Strode, Laurie’s daughter in the
new continuity.
Laurie even tells her daughter that she needs
to step up her security.
“You have no security system Karen."
"Mom, you need help."
So I think Laurie bought this gun for Karen
to protect herself, but Karen is probably
hesitant to use it until later in the movie
when she actually encounters Michael and sees
why he is so dangerous.
In a video I did on the previous Halloween
trailer, which you can watch right here, I
pointed out that some of the trick-or-treaters
were wearing the Silver Shamrock masks from
Halloween 3.
If you’re not familiar with that movie,
Silver Shamrock is an evil company that aggressively
advertises and sells these children’s Halloween
masks that, when activated, cause this to
happen.
In the new trailer, we get a better look at
the masks, and see that all three of them
are present.
Please keep in mind that this does not take
place in the same universe as Halloween 3,
and the appearance of these masks is probably
just an easter egg.
At the end of the trailer, when Laurie is
hysterically waving the gun around, her light
briefly shines onto a closet, where one of
Michael’s victims has been stored on the
top shelf.
At least he’s tidy and organized.
I don’t think OJ Simpson can make that same
claim.
Did you catch anything that I missed in the
trailer?
What do you make of the number 330 being written
on this shack?
What does the text on this Jack-o-Lantern
say?
Would you watch a horror franchise about OJ
Simpson as the slasher, where he’s miraculously
found not guilty at the end of every movie?
Let me know in the comments.
If you learned something new about this trailer
today, leave this video a like And if you
love horror, if you are interested more content
related to the new Halloween film, or if you’re
down to listen to some scary story narrations,
then remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.